abone ol
mi Evet Günaydın arkadaşlar Hoşgeldiniz
çok küçüktüm ortaokul falan sıralarında
Benim okuduğum Okulda da böyle ayda bir
veli toplantısı yapılırdı Bu toplantılar
gece olurdu yaklaşık bu kadar büyük
değilse de buna yakın bir Salonda
yapılan bu toplantıların ayda bir tekrar
söz konusuydu Ben de o toplantılarda
genellikle şiir okur En çok da güzel
okuduğumu söylerdi hocamız Allah rahmet
eylesin Zehra Hanım ve ben kendime çok
güveniyorum Yani ezberimde Çok iyi bu
anlatacağım olay meydana geldi gece hiç
yanıma Şirin Hani metni falan almadan
çıktım Sizin gibi böyle kalabalığı
görünce dondum kaldım bu niye böyle oldu
anlayamadım çünkü çok iyi okuyan
bu güvenen bir adamdım ve tek bir sözcük
aklıma gelmiyor böyle Kudüs falan da yok
ben şifre verilecek bir durum da yok
öğretmenim Zehra Hanım öyle emekleyerek
verdiyse geldi ve bana şiirin ilk
dizisini söyle ben ondan sonra Sular
Seller gibi şiiri tamamladım ama o ilk
dizinin söylenmesinden önce ben sürekli
böyle selam veriyorum veliler öğrenciler
saçın bu vaziyette sonra ikinci selâmı
veriyorum üçüncüsünde kahkaha atmaya
başladı Ben selam vermeye devam ediyorum
Selam gelirsem sanki şiiri hatırlayacak
mısın gibi düşünüyorum işte o Zehra
Hocam Allah rahmet eylesin geldi ve dedi
ki bu düzenin Hani başla ondan sonra
bitirdim fakat nasıl mahcubun Nasıl
utandım inanamazsınız
bu netice itibariyle ertesi gün okul var
tabi gittim Yüzümü kaldıramıyorum Türkçe
dersinde ilk saat hiç unutmuyorum sanki
hiçbir şey olmamış gibi hocam geldi
öğretmenim Önümüzdeki ay ay elinde
tuttuğu şiiri bana verdi bunu çalış bunu
okuyacaksın dedi bu çok önemli bir şey
bence çünkü o hocam bana bunu yapmamış
olsaydı ben bugün sizin huzurunuzda
olamaz gagası çok uzun yıllardır hocalık
yapıyorum hocalık mesleğini yapamaz bana
dokundu beni orada küçük dedi beni
azarlama the beni var etti orada ve ben
ondan sonra hep bu tarz konuşmalar
yaparken şöyle bir kağıdı yanıma alarak
çıkmaya başladım bunu öğrendim ve bunu
pratikte de çok işe yaradığını gördüm o
ve bu Ted'in formatına pek uygun değil
ama ben deme lazım yanında bulunsun
istiyorum Evet şimdi bu Momentum bana
dediler ki Momentum anlat ama onun
üzerine konuşacaksın benimle Fizikten
falan böyle pek anladığımı bir şey değil
ya gerçekten anlamıyorum araştırdım
sonra bizim beraber çalıştığımız
arkadaşlarımızdan bir tanesi böyle
bayağı bu konulara yakın birisidir ona
sordum Hiç merak etme Hocam dedi
hallederiz dedi bana bir takım şeyler
anlattı Benim de kafama yattı bildiğim
anlamın dışında da hani böyle bir
Metafor olarak kullanıldığında çok da
farklı bir şey olmadığını fark ettim
Evet momentun cisimlerin bir kitlelerin
hareketi ile ilgili bir fizik dalı Ben
de iletişim ciğim haspar kadar ben de
insanların ve toplumların vekili şimdi
üzerine anlamı paylaşmakla ilgili
konular üzerine çalışır
bu Fakat daha da önemlisi ya bu giderek
bu iletişimde korkmuş birşey oldu ya
farkında mısınız yani iktidar olmak
istiyorsunuz iletişimi çok iyi bilmek ve
kullanmak durumundasınız Dolayısıyla mal
satmak istiyorsanız iletişim kullanmak
zorundasınız teknolojisi bir taraftan
işin psikolojisi başka bir taraftan
bütün bunlarla uğraşan bir bilim alanı
haline geldi iletişim disiplinlerarası
bir alan yani içinde insan bilimlerinin
bütün dalları var yetmiyor teknolojisi
var evi iletişimle uğraşıyorum dediğimiz
vakitte Bütün bunlardan birşeyleri
dikkate almak öğrenmek bilmek
durumundasınız O nedenle benim burada
anlatacaklarım Aslında bu çok geniş
alanın yüzeyindeki konulara ilişkin
birtakım böyle dokunuşlar olacak her
birinin arka planında çok önemli
teoriler var bunların adını vererek
sıkıcı olmak istemiyorum ama hani bura
o Türkan adamda böyle yüzeysel konuştuk
geçti diye düşünmeyin emin olun dürüst
ve sarılı olarak bunların arka planına
ilişkin de çok şeyi okudum onların
üzerinden sizlere bahsedeceğim Ama
iletişim dediğimiz şey arkadaşlar anlam
paylaşımı Bir kere bu anlamı
paylaşılabilir inmesi için ortak bir dil
üzerinde Konuşmamız gerekiyor ve
birbirimizi dinlememiz gerekiyor
anlamamız gerekiyor gayet güzel fakat
bizim maalesef bir üzerinde durmamız
gereken sıkıntımız var Eğer bu
paylaşımın gerçekleşmesini istiyorsanız
karşınızdaki kişiyi ötekileştirmeye Jack
siniz Bu ötekileştirme çok ciddi bir
problem yani cinsiyetten ötürü
ötekileştirme ırktan ötürü ötekileştirme
Efendim mezhebinden ötürü
ötekileştirmeye karşıdaki pozisyonundan
ötürü ötekini
ve fiziki olarak gözünüzü hoş
görülmediği için ötekileştirme cahil
gördüğünüz için ötekileştirme yaşı
sizden küçük ya da büyük olduğu için
ötekileştirme ve bu konuyu açmadığımız
takdirde iletişim kuramayız Bugün
dünyanın en temel problemlerin başında
bu geliyor teorik olarak baktınız
vakitte gerçekten çok şey yazılıp
çizilen bir konu Şimdi Türkiye'ye
baktığımız vakit bu ötekileştirme ile
ilgili benim çalıştığım üniversitede
Sevgili Hocam Yılmaz eserin yaptığı
değerler araştırması var iki yılda bir
Avrupa ölçeğini Türkiye'de o yönetiyor
şu yüzde yetmiş oranında seyrediyor
Değerli arkadaşlar Bu lgbt bireyleri ile
aynı apartmanda oturmak istemiyorum
diyenler ver İnanmaz bir homofobi
kürdüyle Eğer menisiyle Eller Umut
her yerde oturmak istemiyorum diyenlerin
de oranı yaklaşık bu kadar şimdi böyle
bir durumda hangi paylaşmaktan söz
ediyorsunuz Bence bu noktanın üzerinde
durmakta yarar var bir hepimiz
birbirimizden Farklıyız farklı da
olmamız gerekir Biricik olmamız gerekir
Çünkü bizler her birimiz birisiyiz güzel
Fakat bu farklılıkları böyle
derinleştirmek değil farklılıklar
arasındaki benzerlikleri çoğaltma mısın
Lazım sorun burada bunun içinde
ötekileştirmek ten değil birlikte bir
şeyleri anlamaktan birbirimizi
anlamaktan yola çıkarak bu benzerliği
arttırmak durumunda olmalıyız diye
düşünüyorum şimdi tavamıza birtakım
şemalar var iyilere ilişkin doğru
O şişkin güzellere ilişkin her konuda
her durumda ilgili şamalar var
algıladığımız her bir uyaranı o
aşamalarla ilişkilendiriyor Uz Eğer
kafamıza uyuyorsa Doğrudur diyoruz Tamam
sen bendensin diyoruz değilse
reddediyoruz yanlıştır diyoruz ya da
durup düşünüyoruz ya doğruysa bir
anlamaya çalışayım dediğiniz an işte
iletişim başlıyor demektir bir
arkadaşlar iletişimde iki kişinin
konuşmasında ortak bir noktaya varmak
gerekmiyor birisinin dediğini diğerinin
Evet demesi gerekmiyor Evet ben seni
dinledim ne demek istediğini de anladım
ama katılmıyorum fakat günlük
hayatımızda bu bölümü çalışıyoruz Sizin
dediğinizi karşı taraf Anladım
katılıyorum dediğiniz vakit siz
bozuyorsunuz
var Yani her şeyde bir uzlaşım
içerisinde olma zorunluluğumuz yok bir
dur bakalım bir düşünsün Belki de
gerçekten anladın kabul etmedin neden
kendi değerlerine döndüm neden kabul
etmediğini bir sorgulaya da kabul ettin
Neden kabul ettiğini sorgula İşte bu
şekilde bir sorgulama süreci içerisinde
dilediğimiz Vakit Çok da fazla böyle
düdüklemek ten hani yanında olmak lazım
ama başka bir dünya açılıyor gözümüzü ne
bu dünyanın adı ideoloji Dünyası
arkadaşlar ideoloji günlük hayatımızdaki
Her nesneyi her konuyu her olayı
algılayış ve değerlendir işimizi ana
meselesi benim görsellerin vardır
vallahi bravo Evet teşekkür ederim
arkadaşlar
ve dolayısıyla Dolayısıyla bu mesele ile
ilgili baktığımız vakit bu Momentum Daha
ziyade böyle bir denizde hareket
halindeki cisimlerin den anlatılıyor
biliyorsunuz biz de bir gemiye binmişiz
Arkadaşlar bu geminin şartları da bir
şekilde çalışıyor işte o tahtada belirli
bir yöne hareket ettiren ikiye Biz
ideoloji diyoruz Dolayısıyla bu
ideolojinin farkına vardığımız vakit
bitişin tatlı bir boyutu gözümüzün önüne
serildi veriyor şimdi ideoloji falan
değil de Politik bir konuşma gibi falan
düşünmeyelim yani nefes aldığımız bu
dünyanın Aslında harcı ideoloji bizi
birbirimize bağlayan bizim birbirimize
ilişkilerimizin anlamını üretmemiz de
son derece önemli rol oynayan çok seven
bir kavram şimdi diyorum ki ben bu dünya
O bize öğrettiği doğruları birileri
yapılandırmış nasıl işte televizyondaki
dizilerden özellikle haberlerden çok
fazla konuşan siyasi illerimizin
meselelere ilişkin açıklamalarından
günlük hayattaki pratik lerden
beslenerek birtakım Kafamızda oluşan o
doğruların Eğer yapılandırıldığını
söylüyor Sak bunun çözümle ne bileceğim
i de söyleyebiliriz Bunu çözebilmek
farklı bir dünyanın kapılarını açmak
anlamına geliyor Dolayısıyla bu konuda
Bu konuda da en önemli tetikleyici o
dünyanın kapılarını açma da en önemli
tetikleyici bana göre değil sadece
Birçok insana göre böyle sanat sevgili
arkadaşlar Eğer sanatla ilişkiyi
sağlıklı bir şekil
bu gelirsek Yani bir sanatın pasif
tüketicisi olmak da problem değil Yani
bir sergiye gitmek bir tiyatroya gitmek
bir müzik dinlemek vesaire bu iki pasif
lafını geri alıyor Pasifik en katılmak
onu tüketmek anlamında kullanıyorum ama
bu özellikle işin bir ucundan
tutabiliyor Sak Yani bir konuya girip
orada şarkı söyleye biliyorsak Ne
bileyim panellere katıla biliyorsak
amatör tiyatro yapabiliyorsak İşte o
zaman başka bir boyuta geçmiş oluyoruz O
s**** bize çok başka bir dünyanın
kapılarını aralamaya mıza neden oluyor
Siz perdesini gözümüzün önünden
kaldırıyor Bakın bu harika diye bir
tablo var biliyorsunuz Picasso'nun ilk
başta pek fazla bir şey anlamıyorsunuz
baktığınızda şekillerde senle
bu fakat enteresan inatla bakmaya
anlamaya sormaya sorgulamaya başladınız
vakit bu tabloda Baya ciddi bir şiddeti
ezileni ve ezilenin başkaldırı ışını
haciz ve karşı direnişini anlamaya
görmeye başladınız vakit İşte o Siz
perdiste kalkmış oluyor benim yine çok
sevdiğim bir şiir var size Onu
okuyacağım Başkan güzel bir Nazım Hikmet
şiiri okudu çok severim ben de bir
okuyayım bakalım Melike de tam Dayın
ağaç şiiri tanıdığım bir ağaç var Etlik
bağlarına yakın Sadettin Adını bile
duymamış tanrının işine bakın Geceyi
gündüzü biliyor dört mevsim Rüzgarı karı
ay ışığına bayılıyor ama kötüleniyor
karanlık ona bir kitap vereceğim
rahatını kaçırmak için bir öğrenegörsün
aşk
çok acı o vakit seyredin Dolayısıyla
işte sanat da böyle bir etkiye sahip bir
kitap gibi okuduğunuzda ki sayfaların
arasından başka bir bir ışık sizi
karşılıyor o bakımdan Bence Oo
bastırılmış Çünkü hayatımız bu Yüksek
hızda B şiddetli bir şekilde gelişen bu
Mert onun karşısında giderek böyle
kendimizi geriye çekme yalnızlaşma beden
öğrenilmiş çaresizlik diye
adlandırdığımız duruma bir kabullenme
hali içerisinde yaşamanın sonucunda bir
depresyon içinde geçiyorum Dolayısıyla
buna başkaldırmak durumundayız umudu
asla ve asla kaybetmek durumundayız Umut
birbirimize birbirimizle beraber
olmaktan geçiyor Dolayısıyla sokağa
çıkmak gerekiyor Dolayısıyla Baş
bu beraber olmak gerekiyor Yani sivil
toplum kuruluşlarının içerisinde siyasi
partilerin içerisinde sanat oluşumları
içerisinde okuma grupları içerisinde Ama
birileri olacak o birileriyle birlikte
birbirimizi anlayarak çoğu almamız
gerekiyor burada Hem birbirimizi
anlayacağız hem de Biricik olacağız
Biricik olduğunuz vakit bunun
sorumluluğunu taşıyarak kendimizi bari
edeceğiz Burası önemli var etmek demek
hayatımıza ilişkin birtakım soruların
yanıtını bulmak için çaba harcamak demek
ben nereye gidiyorum nasıl gidiyorum
hangi değerleri koruyarak kollayarak
kendimi geliştirerek nereye varacağım ve
de Bütün bunlar için ne yapacağım işte
bu ne yapacağımı sorusunun altında
cesaret merak
A B D İnadına yaşama arzusu olması
gerekiyor iletişim Sizin nasıl var
olduğunuzla ilgili bir tarz olarak
karşımıza çıkıyor Siz neyseniz
iletişiminiz de o iletişiminiz Neyse siz
de o'sunuz o nedenle şu ya da bu şekilde
bildiğimiz bu gemilerin içerisinde o
düğmenin başında Biz var mıyız yok muyuz
var olabilmek için ne yapmamız gerekiyor
kiminle Neyi görüşmemizde konuşmamız
kimin neden anlamamız gerektiği ve bu
dünyada var olabilmenin yolu nereden
geçiyorsa onu ne unu ışığıyla onun
yatırımıyla kendimizi geleceğe taşımamız
Biz tekrardan önemli oluyor Dolayısıyla
iletişim Evet anlam paylaşımı Ama bu
anlamları paylaşırken de kendimize
bakmamız
bu ve kendimizden yola çıkarak
başkalarına bakmamız ve başkalarını
anlayarak kendimizi üretmemiz büyütme
miz ve bu var olma süreci içerisinde bir
şekilde yürümemiz gerekiyor Evet benim
söyleyeceklerim bu kadar ümit ederim bir
takım mesajları birtakım düşüncelerimi
sizlerle paylaşma imkanı bulmuşumdur Çok
teşekkür ediyorum sağ ol